[Music]
that ending I know so magical a magical
and I remember shooting it and being
like man this feels really right I think
it's like ultimately if you're so torn
also you're so fulfilled when you watch
it you're like oh thank goodness right
what is that floating kiss at the end of
this movie what does it signify to you I
think I think it's usually reserved for
first kisses feelings like that but when
you kiss somebody and you just feel like
you're lifting into it into outer space
it's just like so right so great and
yours mmm yeah it's that moment of
reconnection it's beautiful I mean it's
kind of like when when you're in love
right and if you're truly in love I
think the world kind of just falls away
and it's just you and that person and I
think that that's what we were trying to
do and ultimately you we didn't even
want people to necessarily notice it
just like with a feeling of us bringing
up I'm sad because oh they're on a crane
going up and I think we've I think
hopefully we pulled it up mommy what
happened I don't even notice a that I
went back and I watched I was like
that's how I felt but then they're
actually learning yes we promised that
we were not going to break each other's
hearts yeah well I I think that we both
made promises we couldn't keep
right we gotta talk about what Peter and
Laura Jean went through obviously there
was a breakup in this movie how do you
think or how do you want fans to feel
about that man well I think they'll be
crushed you know you never want to see a
couple break up but I think ultimately
they get back together so it's a little
bit of hope right like you can have
problems and challenges and issues in a
relationship and and work through them
and even come out stronger after after
those issues and I think that's so
exciting I think fans are gonna love
that I'm excited for them to see that I
think they're gonna feel way more I
think a lot of people are going in like
Peter Kaminsky fans and I think the
movie really honestly sways that so I
think people are gonna feel confused
like I felt confused everyday driving
home from work I was like what's Happ
what what is she going through what's
happening I'm conflicted as well so I
hope I hope that they feel confused
because that I'm like I did my job right
ending setup the third movie would you
say y'all ready for the third movie
that's all I can say it's it's yeah I
haven't seen it cover-to-cover
but uh the storyline is one of my
favorites of the three I mean I think
she just really starts to make decisions
for herself
that might be unpopular but I think at
the end of the day I was a young woman
like you have to protect your own heart
and make the decisions I feel truly
right for you regardless of other people
that surround you and I think at the end
of the day Lara Jean loves love and she
loves the guys but at the end today I
know that she's good on her own as well
so we'll see but it's very satisfying
like yeah girl get your life
book right we see them in college yeah
so is that gonna follow suit with a
third movie there's a lot like a lot of
the third movie is based off around
college yeah and I think we tackle like
the third movie is definitely the most
mature movie out of it all and we tackle
a lot of like first like questions and
first - you know actions and stuff so
it's definitely we tackle more like real
real life because there's really no
distractions it's just him and I and
figure it out
[Music]